I think part of the, really
important part of the process
of package lifecycle
and package development
is not just adding
new functions,
but it is equally important
to remove those functions.
And we know that removing
functions that used to work
is frustrating.
And so we have developed this
process, this lifecycle process
of deprecation where it starts
with pretty mild warnings
and gets progressively
aggressive, more
and more aggressive over time.
We hope this is useful.
We hope that this
gradually pushes
you towards the golden
path without forcing you rudely
when you're working
on something else
to urgently switch something.
But at the same time,
we believe that we want
these functions to be better.
We want these things to
have a more consistent,
cohesive syntax
because that makes
it easier for future users.
And I think we're
doing pretty well.
We've certainly
got a lot better,
I think, at handling
deprecation and breakages,
but we're certainly still
trying, still learning.
And if you have any
feedback, please let us know.